[Megatron] Decepticons,
finish this war!
[Decepticons grunt]
-Optimus, go!
-[growls] For Cybertron!
[Prime grunting]
-[loud clank]
-[Prime groans]
[growling]
I won't let you… destroy… Cybertron!
[Prime groaning]
And I won't let you enslave it!
-[groans]
-This will be extinction!
-[Prime grunting]
-[Megatron] Give me the Allspark!
-[Prime grunts]
-[Megatron groans]
-[Decepticons growls]
-[Prime grunts]
The circle closes, Prime.
You are defeated...
and the Allspark
will help me wipe out
what's left of the Autobots.
Not today!
-[Megatron growls]
-[Prime grunts]
-[Megatron groans]
[both growling]
[Prime grunts]
[Megatron grunts]
No!
Decepticons,
kill them!
[Decepticons grunting]
-[loud blast]
-[Megatron grunts]
For Cybertron!
[roars]